was ist das gegenteil von einem gangster
rapper die frage müsse ein klauten wer
ist das gegenteil von einem gangster
rapper ich glaube es ist im city welten
hat so viel spaß gemacht rap zu hören
wie bei ihm und er kommt zu clixoom wir
reden mit ihm über den spaßfaktor mct
und wir reden natürlich über eure fragen
die am besten unter dieses video postet
in den kommentaren oder er klickt dann
eben da gibt es einen button video
upload ladet eine frage hoch und klickt
informell tagenden wichtige
informationen die unbedingt lesen müsst
und dann kann eigentlich nichts mehr
schiefgehen würde ich mal sagen und ein
schlusswort lautet wie immer bis dann
bleibt dran